gingiva not the idea in me and for the
gentleman
oh yeah yeah I came up with a good with
the story I read it and I thought it was
awesome I thought it was great and I as
I read it I read about the character
that Ryan Ryan
it's Ryan Braun the play and I said and
I with great enthusiasm I called up the
producers and I said this is great I
can't wait to give up and not a great
park why don't we see if we can get this
is a great park for Ryan Gosling
I'm sorry I'm probably more nervous than
you are sorry that's not comforting I'm
not going to say that wasn't very
professional I'm so scared my hands are
shaking but you don't hear that
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you do seem happy in your work good I
like doing it
Brendan's went with the Obamas you were
at the famous lost kind of white house
party I was there it was scary it was
sad I remember I I just remember like
hanging out and like first of all every
black person was there jay-z Beyonce
dyed it with the black heaven I remember
at one point of the night I was like
with Michelle Obama and she was like
kind of sad and she's like I don't know
what we're gonna do I don't know what's
gonna happen and I was like and she
looks at me and she goes I was talking
about the country got a picture of you
here you are
yes in the White House I met the man oh
look that was great
sharing laughs you know remember what
you were laughing about ya know exactly
wasn't about her to me
[Laughter]
nobody's talking to it
President Obama at the time was telling
me that I was his second favorite
character in the wire oh hey number one
yeah Omar was his favorite laughed out
loud as you can see like the world
changing lead a judge of whether or not
it's delicious
no I like that it has just enough
Christmas in it here's the thing no it's
very good that's right
you wants it wants it home drank from
this side so you could drink from there
you can see from the other side
no is this like feeding a gremlin after
midnight
[Applause]
so now we're going to drop down
[Laughter]
I met I met I met at weapons here I met
Denzel Denzel and open at the same time
it was what it was this this segue it
was just this leg I don't know black
african-american excellent segue or
blanket so came up to me because I you
came talking English accent that yeah
mate yeah cheers mate cheers mate cheers
me and I'm like what what's happening
how do you know anyways in grammar I
swear is just premium I've never but
when I do I'm gonna hug her for sure
at the Golden Globes but she was too far
away you got inhale deeply
[Applause]
they're not like you okay
[Music]
[Applause]
okay is that good
okay okay yeah let's watch back let's
watch back you okay
[Music]
[Applause]
had a break she was filming but she was
in costume and we were there just
visiting we hadn't started work yet and
the first idea of the second ad said
would you like to meet the hell I'm here
and I said yeah I'd love to
so she walked from like a hundred yards
away dressed and as Morgan le Fay and
Cairns my oldest friend and we both went
[ __ ] it's a jungle inside so somewhere
deep inside at the end
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
survival your only go
plunge the jewel inside say the name of
the game
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Jeffrey Cersei Ilyn Payne the mountain
beric Dondarrion Cyrus of man the red
woman
Tom Hanks
[Applause]
[Music]
you